i think at some point we're just going
to end up getting covet but i i feel
better that we at least are we have some
protection against it morel durham is
taking her kids to get their second
covet shots but she's in the minority i
find this is a missed opportunity
because we have a really well evaluated
vaccine also for children parental
hesitancy is understandable everyone
wants only what's best for their kids
but is messaging partly to blame our
national advisory committee on
immunization says two doses may be
offered to children 5 to 11 not should
and families can face a barrage of
misinformation in chat groups and less
than credible sources there's no doubt
in my mind that the effects of the
illness itself both short term and long
term are much more detrimental to
children than the vaccine health canada
says no safety concerns were found in
clinical trials of pfizer's pediatric
shot and recent data from the u.s where
more than 8.6 million doses have been
administered to kids 5 to 11 reveals
side effects are exceedingly rare
calgary pediatric emergency physician
stephen friedman studied
hospitalizations in kids who do get
covet and stresses the importance of
vaccination what our study shows if
they're severe enough to be hospitalized
they have a risk of a severe adverse
outcome but shot or not experts admit
omicron is now changing the landscape i
think it's really important that we
strongly advocate for the vaccines for
those who are vulnerable to uh
landing in hospital that's been the
power of the vaccines and and that's
still holding true with omicron but i
also think that we have to be honest uh
about
that the vaccines are not in fact
stopping transmission if they did we
wouldn't be in this situation a
situation we have to adapt to but the
science is clear vaccination is still
the best option we have to protect
ourselves and our kids against covet 19.
jamie morocco global news toronto